we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's take our next caller from the 763
area code caller what's your name and
where are you calling from today hi I'm
calling from [ __ ] Rapids Minnesota how
are you today David doing well last
night well just curious I was watching
over one of your money or more recent
videos and with the Reverend guy and he
asked you know where's the violence in
the right wing and I just happened to
thank you know with the Bundy ranch in
to them then the government takeover
incident and then there was actually a
couple of cops that got shot and killed
by right-winger just down south in Iowa
why do you think it is that the police
department seem to align more with the
right wing more than the left wing you
know I don't know they're sure whether
that's true and I think it probably
depends on where in the country you are
I have spoken to a number of different
both officers and sort of like street
level patrol officers and also
higher-ups at different Massachusetts
police departments and I found are
admittedly surprisingly based on my
preconceived notions some pretty
enlightened and sort of progressive
thinking in many cases so I think that
you're you're right that in the same way
that broadly speaking the military
probably leans slightly more right than
left I think that there's still a lot of
progressive thinking within police
departments around the u.s. now what
you're referring to though is when I was
interviewed by Jesse Lee Peterson on his
program and it was an absolute gong show
and a lot of people have advised me
never to go back on that guy's program
again that just was completely unable to
even understand conceptually what I was
saying so that it he was just he wasn't
even really addressing any of what I was
saying and it was sort of an exercise in
futility they have invited me back on
you might be interested to know but
right now I'm leaning against doing it
it just seemed like a pointless exercise
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't die that was
that was just amazing and at one point
they said the phrase and I quoted it
he's a fast guy he likes information the
context of trying to use as an insult
against you just wait a minute yeah
after we went off the air they continue
to sort of like do post game analysis
because he's a fax guy who wants to like
investigate things and find stuff out as
like yes that was the reason why we
weren't able to be on the same page and
do you think his burden of proof
argument wasn't do you think your burden
of proof argument wasn't getting through
to him oh my god would be just
pretending that it wasn't so he wouldn't
have to address it no I think he
genuinely didn't understand like but
afterwards I realized what I should have
said to him is how do you prove that
something didn't happen like what would
be an example of proof of something that
didn't happen and my guess is he would
have just said something like Occupy
Wall Street or something like that
anyway thanks so much for the call
appreciate hearing from you and a good
good question and a good point and I
appreciate you making it no problem
Thanks
all right take care always great to hear
from people in all over the country
people really calling in from all over
the world today I would say